welcome Burt Warlow Burt Burt young
according to our mother run citizens
what's up buddy
well I'm here in New York I my new movie
from Warner Brothers is gonna premiere
it's going to be available for digital
download tomorrow Oh No yeah that's a
great Batman vs two-face
oh no Harvey Weinstein oh [ __ ] great
movie great yeah and who's playing
two-face Oh William Shatner really so
here you have the two most iconic TV
shows in history Batman and Star Trek
that's right the actors working together
oh it's an animation that's right to a
to face a Animated Feature October the
8th on blu-ray on DVD October the 17th
that's awesome yeah it's it's it it's a
great flick and we had a tremendous
turnout at Comic Con yesterday who did
that man Adam West did before yeah oh my
god and he was great he's great in it
and it's very exciting and Warner
Brothers just made a tremendous project
out of it that's awesome so you you
gotta be happy that that got finished
taping yeah you know they when they when
they do this they record you prior to
the animation and then there's a year of
animation all right so the recording
stuff was first and and then they did
the animation when did you get
comforting you play Robin Moore in the
film when did you get comfortable
revisiting the Robin role I'm sure I
never left yeah I understand I I go out
on weekends and I at these giant Comic
Cons all over the country last weekend I
was in Hamilton north of Toronto and the
San Diego one yes but the San Diego one
basically has been taken over by the
studios in other words they literally do
all promote their new movies there and
stuff like that you can't even get a
hotel room there the studio's booked all
the hotel rooms you have to have a
special pass to go into a hotel you
couldn't even eat at lunch there so for
me it's not as much fun as going to the
ones that are all throughout the country
New York smaller ones right yeah are you
still I mean I imagine a comic-con
you're still a really a long line I mean
I mean Robin Batman and Robin people
really want to oh all day long they do
all day long
I mean well let me give you
a demand eyerly er this year headed up
at Dallas comic-con 80,000 paid
attendance she says last August in
Toronto 160,000 paid attendance to see
us those are huge numbers yeah I mean
you look back burn Ward Adam West photo
would have been nice to get a picture
with those two together I mean that's
already [ __ ] awesome yeah well we we
have autographed photos and we sign them
for fans and stuff like that so it's
it's a tremendous turnout do you feel
like the Lions gotten longer since Adam
passed like meaning like people like all
let me jump on this you know I I guess
maybe because they think well geez we
lost one right we better go see we're
kind of morbid yeah you know you you I
have noticed that there's a lot of a lot
of people coming and they want to say hi
a lot of people you know express regret
that they didn't have a chance to meet
Adam did it hurt your career at all you
played Robin or such a night it's such
an iconic role and after you're done
with that are you kind of typecast
where's it hard to get other stuff well
you know here's the way I look at it you
know if you have a cup here and it's a
hundred percent full it could be full
with like 50 different movies right or
supporter we know it's for one or two
major projects right right and and and
and so it's still full and so for me
Batman is you know worldwide it was
number one show in the world
it's still shown in every state in the
United States every single day it's only
400 countries now is still around the
world and the Batman merchandise my gosh
they have well first of all they have a
Batman 66 comic book series that is
drawn just to match me yeah Adam you
know some of that money off that right
enough to buy a cup of coffee there it
is okay it's not in New York no when you
when you audition for Batman you get
this role you're an act you want to be
an actor you're an actor what were you
doing right before that I was selling
real estate and I was studying acting
professionally and and I was going to
UCLA in the acting class but also
studying professionally I sold a house
to a producer who sent me to an agent
the agent said you know I can't get work
for the actors I got so don't expect to
work for a year and if you do you get a
you know one liner and the for nothing
they pitch in the world no not at all
enough to
to depress you but they called me up
somebody from that office that said we
don't know what it is but there's
something going on over 20th century-fox
go over there tomorrow afternoon
I went over there had no idea what it
was and I met a casting director who
said would you like to meet the
executive producer I figured everybody
gets to meet the executive producer
which isn't the case but I didn't know
that and I went and I saw William Dozier
and I said hello sir and I shook his
hand and he kind of looked at me was
kind of surprised I was so aggressive
and he said you're kind of big for this
role and I said open I promise you sir I
won't grow anymore well I have to I mean
who could stop that sure and he said
would you like to do a screen test I
figured everybody got to do a screen
test
that's not the case either right so I
went in the weeks later I did a screen
test had no idea what it was you know
you know was about man
I had I had two pages of dialogue so in
that note I was Bruce and Dick didn't
say my Batman didn't say Bruce Wayne or
dick great it just said Bruce so you
weren't in the Robin costume it for the
screen shot well not at the beginning
right and then I I did I did the
dialogue still didn't know what it was
and I said thank you very much I started
to leave they said wait a minute we're
not done with you yet you know there's a
trailer over there at the end of the
soundstage we want you to go over there
and there's two wardrobe men and they're
waiting to help you get dressed I said
well I'm perfectly capable dressing
myself that oh no you don't understand
yeah you go over there were they hiding
it or they thought you know no no is
flesh-colored so I went over there I got
in the trailer and this like like 12
foot long it's like I'm bad with a ton
of different clothes on there and I said
am I putting some of this on they said
no you're putting all of it on I said
what and I this most uncomfortable
costume in my entire life was it made of
wool the the vest Bob Hope right through
the t-shirt but that wasn't the worst
it's that the tights that whoever was
there that was designing them decided
they didn't like to tense so they they
colored them and when they did all the
fabric filled up and it there's no air
in it okay oh I see all the pourer that
was know right and and as I stepped out
of the sounds out of the trailer I said
to the two guys I said you know
it's a good thing I'm just doing this
quick screen test and I never have to
wear this costume again famous last
words
Wow because I do they make any
adjustments to it for you did you say
like million different and just they did
right yeah yeah yeah I mean the cape was
pulling my neck back you know I mean
everything was the the mask was
irritating my eye Lorne is like some
kind of torture yeah you know I mean and
how do you do your lines and how do you
be enthusiastic yeah yeah yeah oh no
they would pull back on your neck yes
that well they powered it was the cave
don't you think bridle said it was very
heavy because I was about eight pounds
oh my god shorter than Batman right
right but I had snaps put on the on the
ship and the show shoulders of the to
take the weight off how big was it was
that was Adams did he have the same
complaint you did the same costume
complaint his cowl was driving him crazy
his what his cowl that he put over his
head oh why is so hot in there and and
you know it was kind of funny though
when I first saw him in the custom and I
still didn't know it was for Batman I
didn't grow up seeing Batman comic books
there was only Superman where I lived
right I didn't know who Batman was and I
see this
and he looks cross-eyed in his mask I
mean this is so hilarious you just you
know and he said I look like a raccoon
with my so the two of us we started
laughing before we did the screen test
we've laughed for 50 years since so I
said he hated wearing that it was it was
a hard plastic yo it was known as
fiberglass wrap I burger
yes fiberglass wrapped in cloth and
stuff Wow
so it was believe me it was not a lot of
fun wow that's very funny a little meets
a little what just these little I don't
see him coming up yeah you know I do
have something that ironic I'd like to
share with you sure I know Adam and I
would I go out on these weekends and we
go do the panels we talk about all the
questions people want to ask and stuff
like that but when Adam first comes out
I'm already out there and he'll come out
and he'll say ladies and gentlemen I'm
just gonna stand here a few extra
moments and allow you to admire my
incredible physical development and
people start laughs sure
and he said would you like to know how
at 88 years old I'm in such great shape
and and they say well yeah yeah he says
every morning I have a bowl of Burt Ward
gentle giants dog food and that keeps me
in shape people are laughing and
laughing and the irony of it is that you
know I don't know if you know this my
wife and I operate the largest giant
breed dog risk in the world sure sure
sure twenty you love animals kids and I
know but because you know yes I do but
but you know because the giant breeds
live the shortest lifespan you know some
of them only 5 or 6 years some of them
sad love them so my wife and I when we
would lose one we get so upset so we
decided that we would find a way if we
could to help him live longer and what
we did is we spent millions of dollars
of our own money develop a dog food that
is different than every other food in
the world our dogs including giant
breeds are living up to 27 years 27
years yes healthy and active so healthy
the only time they go to a vet is every
three years for $10 rabies updates so me
ask you question what is your what kind
of work does your wife do you have
millions of dollars you didn't make
millions from Batman right there no no
well my wife my wife's name is Tracy
Posner ward her father was Victor Posner
Forbes 400 what'd he do Wow
when I met my wife in 1989 she and her
long after bat okay yeah she and her
father owned thirty three thousand six
hundred companies with annual sales of
twenty six billion all a hundred
thousand employees I'll name two
companies she owned once called Arby's
they make roast beef sandwiches like RC
Cola you know yeah and when I met her
she and her father every week we're
buying a company averaging 150 to 200
million a week and she's a big animal
lover and so she had gosh unbelievable
how did you meet her her father sent her
out with ten million dollars to buy an
interest in my publicly traded company
that I was running see besides being an
actor I'm a business person as well and
she and I talked for 12 hours straight
fell in love she called her father and
said dad I'm moving to California and
marrying an actor which you believe me
it was the most after you met once
yes we've talked for 12 hours straight
we fell in love
were you wearing the tights at the time
no I was not wear them for
trick-or-treating and very private
moments with my wife I gotta ask you
have you ever dressed up like Robin for
a woman come on you must is my wife
yeah she's asked you to dress up like
that of course and then she puts it on
but she looks better the costume tonight
of course yeah so you met you fall in
love how long after are you married or
how long after are you living together
well we know two weeks later she went
back got her stuff moved to California
and and her father had always told her
as a child
whatever you do don't ever get involved
with an actor and don't ever you know go
to Hollywood and she did both of them
okay and he actually called me up and
offered me ten million dollars to send
her back are you kidding no I'm not no
no marrying into that fortune out of
kept her too smart to no wait no no that
wasn't about money oh sorry I was in
love with you in the math I was in love
with her okay and so I told her father I
said thank you very much for the offer
but you know I really you know I love
your daughter I want to marry her yeah
you would have thought a father would
not have called and told that to his
daughter right right he just tried to
sabotage when she didn't even date
anybody in here the first time she falls
in love in her life and he's gonna
sabotage he calls her and tells her that
he did that I guarantee you that was a
test
what did she love my daughter or does he
want she called me up and she was madder
than hell she said you are a schmuck you
should have taken the 10 million I'm not
going anywhere
10 million and she's and then not live
but I wasn't interested in it was it was
long I've been married for 28 years
we're incredibly happy and we do this
dog rescue we take no money from this we
don't take a dime and we now have our
dog food going national right here in
New York at the end of this job will be
in 700 stop stop and shops so this is
basic for you it's a labor of love
already have money so you don't need the
money this is something we want to do
and what we do is we've made a food Bend
and our whole thought was how about all
the people that love their dogs that
can't afford to buy the top or get the
top vet care and they can't and even the
expensive foods don't keep dogs living
we're in I'm up doc so what did we do
we made the finest food in the world we
sell it at
it retails for half the price that's
what you would buy in a pet store and
our whole motto is half the price and
twice the life you're a nice man you are
a nice man was her dad annoyed when you
put out your tell-all book where there
was there anything any what you ought to
be about that no I wasn't well because
he really he actually he was very nice
to me he really was he just didn't want
us to move to California so he offered
an amazing amount of money to run his
empire and you know and to give me a
pittance to work with her right we we
want you know I'm an actor and I live
out in California because that's where
the work is sure so we we didn't take
that offer but you know you guys turn
down a lot of money from this guy money
and everything and I tell people and in
my case it's nothing no no is if it's it
just that we we think there's more
important things to do and there's 80
million dogs in the United States and 67
million household think of all these
people senior citizens who our kids have
left and now that all they've got is
that dog and they love that dog like
their own kid yeah this has your
question too your book was about like a
lot of the girls and all this stuff and
then you have all this harvey weinstein
spoke has Hollywood changed a lot like
Harvey said I came from this era of howl
like he I came up in the 60s and 70s
like that's true certain things back
then we're probably more acceptable
exactly what exactly but not now I mean
of course the dangers and all this stuff
of you know transmittal of you know
diseases yeah not the same world anymore
well plus I mean Harvey Weinstein was
jerking off into plants I don't think
that was ok in the 6th probably not no
that's you know it's it's unfortunate
but apparently it's a huge scandal yeah
did you see evidence not from him but
from other guys in that kind of position
like would you see producers or
directors kind of taking advantage of
their position I'm sure it happened I
didn't watch it
you know sure no but you could tell that
you know they were I mean you know it's
like you know if you want to get a job
then you know you're gonna have to put
out you know and and I you know and and
some women did and some didn't and some
men had to I've heard I always pause
there's rumors that Burt Reynolds is get
has a book
for when he dies where he had talked
about sex with producers again it's only
a rumor but you know a lot of handsome
guys probably hit that but I've heard
that rumor that like as soon as he dies
like it's ready to go it's ready to go
out right I know but it's just a rumor
yeah you never know you know what I mean
you never know but so for us I mean and
my wife and I we live very healthy I
gotta tell you a lot of the actors that
we're working when I was working I mean
they're on drugs and they were alcohol
and you know they're not around you ever
do any drugs or not never Wow never
smoked never drank never took any drugs
and my wife and I are very health
oriented you know yeah and we're healthy
knock on wood and we intend to stay that
way so you're happy you didn't blow it
like a lot of guys that's right and you
you know and now I we we have the
greatest time I have you know I have 50
dogs living in my house at all tipsy oh
my god what's it fits a lot of duty well
no but the thing is is it you're when
you save these dogs I mean we've been
doing this 23 years fifteen thousand
five hundred dogs rescued 23 years every
one of them would have been put to death
and we saved him we spent all the money
for their medical death while over there
crime scene nothing oh look the problem
is overpopulation
and what it is do you know that every
single moment finally in the United
States more than a million dogs are put
to death every single month 70% of which
are puppies so you want to get that
number up zero I like to take it and the
way to do it is to stop the overbreeding
make these breeders guarantee that if
they can't do that dog right they're
gonna take care of it for life
Bob watch that that coming down it's not
fair to kill an innocent animal I agree
are you vegetarian or vegan I eat very
healthy I'm not I'm not a vet you know I
like the animals but it's kind of hard
I'm not willing to commit to that level
it's delish you know and stuff like that
yeah they're annoying to the bed pets
that's right but I actually have a I
have 84 of them 84 fish yes you're
number but I have I have a koi pond
oh he's giant Oh bunch of guys named Joe
yeah and they they're they're they're
magnificent you're Giants so you live in
like like it like how many animals are
your property
well there's more than 50 dogs yeah at
50 do you have somebody that cleans up
after me why don't you hire somebody I
don't know we have people that some of
that okay yeah course a lot of our hair
of the dog
we feed 600 pounds of our dog food every
day just giant we do that if our staff
yeah that's a lot you know what I mean
and and but this is you know and it
works out great we have a beautiful 5 or
5 acre estate in the heart of the city
you know 15,000 square foot city LA no
it's a little city called Norco it's the
last winter show on Netflix last western
town in America where horses have a
right away over cars
do they really in fact if you drive down
our street you know how you have your
dotted white lines you don't see it
there you see the dotted red white and
blue lines it's very well what's it what
state it's called is California it's by
Riverside it's halfway between LA and
Palm Springs but all and they have
exotic animals in that city like one of
our neighbors yeah and she goes out of
town her pet comes over and stays in our
house with with our dogs and her pet as
a camel really she's a pet camel yeah
yeah okay a photo of it I can show you
let me s like would you say that taking
care of a camel smells worse or when you
walked into this room because I have to
apologize for my co-host he's been
having a gassy morning no I and I wanted
I almost like gonna say we should do the
interview outside cuz I'm sure you
noticed that no I did realizing no it's
fine again I have a nose clip on yeah no
but seriously no I know camels are
believe me you know you'd think 30 no
not dirty what Jim is yeah no you you
deal with a lot of dogs playing me
dropping a little wind sometimes my
grandmother would always say that I
dropped a little wind yeah did you did
you for a whole bunch before he came in
here and did I make that up yeah did I
yes he did
so anyway I'm it's great to be here and
robin or all-american apple pie they
certainly are but they also cut yes
there's a good part of being no I don't
and you're totally antiseptic no you're
absolutely oh man can you imagine how
bad those tights must have stunk
they guys they covered up the pores with
the dye so that means you have to put
them on like
three times a day yeah but when you're
farting in the time we don't it's just
capturing everything
how many uniforms did you have at six at
all times because of the fight scenes
you know and I love the fight scenes
because I'm a black belt in karate are
you really
oh yeah in fact a piece of trivia for
you I lived in the same complex that
Bruce Lee lived in did you know him of
course yet we used to spar together and
yes and in fact when I was doing Batman
and I had met him he his wife Linda and
he at the time brand and his son was six
months of age and we would go down into
Chinatown and order all the most
authentic food because he lived in China
for Hong Kong for ten years but when I
fought Bruce a piece of trivia is that
Bruce Lee's first filmed fight scene of
his career was fighting me on Batman and
that and from there he became the most
famous cinema martial artist in the
world that's that's amazingly sparred
with Bruce lo yeah two years ago I was
just inducted into the International
karate and kickboxing Hall of Fame which
was a great honor and don't know it's
been you know it's been for me and I
started in 1959 the same year it came to
the United States I was a first-year
karate game but but it's funny you look
at at Burt Ward you know your history as
an actor right and you could sit in the
room of a lot of people and know if
anyone said who in here sparred with
Bruce Lee like you would ever have
nobody we'd never have yes right what
kind of a guy was he cuz he's a guy that
you hear only about in legend you don't
very few people later I've interviewed
have actually hung out with him and
spoken to him yeah
well I know I I mean I saw him quite a
bit and he trained eight hours a day I
mean he trained eight hours a day and he
he was he was cocky but but he's also a
very nice guy you know and he was very
very smart
was he nicer to you because he like you
knew him before he was a famous guy we
treat you different because you kind of
were part of the way in part responsible
or at the be at the beginning when it
blow up ya know he was always very nice
to me you know I I think you know
everybody had just a Fame in their own
way right but he was always very nice to
me did he changing it more cocky I don't
think so I just think that he be you
know so many people like we're trying to
come at him for this
and you know and it ends up where many
times actors will kind of almost regress
into a shell type of thing for self
emotional preservation but he was really
great guy and very nice to me
and and they had wonderful sense of
humor he's just really nice nice guy so
karate do you still take it or did you
stop taking it well no you yeah I
stopped years ago but just you don't
forget it I mean it's nothing that you
know and it's a great note to stay in
condition and one of my one of my other
friends recently passed away as well was
was Bob Chaney when the eight he was
eighth degree black belt he won the
World Championship 1972 and was
considered pound profound them of the
most part the best fighter in the world
in March in in karate and he was a
personal friend of mine for 20 years and
these people are there they they train
but you know I got to tell you something
when you train at that level I mean and
you get older I mean all kinds of things
you have hip replaced right and from and
and and and from kicking so much and
yeah and I mean it takes a toll on the
human body so I didn't want to go that
far you know what I mean I I got it you
know because I thought it was great
exercise and you know protection and
self-protection but I never wanted to
get to a point where you know what I
mean that it would it long-term have a
you know bad effect sure so you you are
in the fight scenes you are much more
qualified than Adam West oh of course I
love to do my own fight scenes and what
was kind of interesting sometimes they
actually got real we see we see one
choice I just think a little bit I never
knew this now watching this knowing this
I want to see what it looked like yeah
we fight scenes okay we're the stuntmen
weren't careful and they'd hit me sure I
really hit him back you would oh yeah
they say we gotta stop this you know
it's called a receipt yeah you give him
a receipt today would hit you and you
would strike back so what you kind of uh
will you a bit too aggressive sometimes
because you knew you could really fight
[ __ ] strong as they say I wouldn't go
that far right but nobody I enjoyed I
enjoyed the fight scenes they were great
and I mean you can watch me on the thing
I loved it I I that was the best part
for who play bad girl no Vincent Price
well who played better all right
no he's there live on Craig yeah yeah
with anybody hitting that on the set
no no not Adam you know let me tell you
something when you're running on a set
and you are in there for business you
are there for business yeah they can go
out and have their private lives also
but you're there it's very serious it's
very expensive per hour you've got 80
guys on the crew we had a double-sized
cruise because of all the explosions and
and effects and stuff like that and yeah
you can see right there you know the
people fighting Jerry that's right Louis
he was on our show but he came out of
the window that I don't think that was
him I look like him yeah he yeah I don't
know who I don't know who is that I
don't know you're watching no but it was
it was a great show and you know today
people watch it every single day turn
our new movie is gonna already gonna be
a huge hit the pre-orders are gigantic
the new movie by the way is Batman
versus two faces an animated feature and
digital release is October 8th blue neon
tomorrow dr. Burton tomorrow okay night
and then it releases tomorrow right so
that's when you get it get it on iTunes
get it on all those services yeah and
then in a week they'll have a blu-ray
and I'll tell you they really gave a
really special account one let me tell
you something there is a featurette on
this DVD yeah that they did call the
wonderful world of Burt Ward which I'm
really honored to have done and they
they put it out and talked about my
friendship with Adam for years talks
about our dog rescue and how we saving
animals and you know saving dogs and and
the irony for me was that I would have
died here I can double and triple a
lifespan of a dog but my dear friend who
I really love I couldn't help him live
any longer double he's 80
we put in 240 years old yeah well yeah
that dog food gave him alive for a while
well right yeah I'm healthy never oh he
was very healthy how was it me though
pardon me how old would he eat you never
had an offset romp with Catwoman come on
I would have no I would have looked she
should've let her know it's lady very
nice we had three cat women you know yes
you did and then why would they quit
when they get old and disgusting or no
no no
No when we did the Batman movie Julie
Newmar was doing McKenna's gold another
movie so they had to hire and they hire
another person to play cat what about
you did the Batman movie yes I did no
yeah Adam Weston yeah and with the four
villains and the penguin submarine and
all that kind of idealized movies not
just episodes yeah big feature film were
they popular very popular and in costume
no I didn't I didn't I at the time my
daughter was being born so I I stayed
and you know it was there but Adam was
there and this was in Austin Texas in
1966 you can you pull up the picture of
the three Catwoman there Troy is right
on yeah yeah cats women there you are
Illya and Meriwether and there's the kid
and Eartha Kitt all right so forgot
Eartha Kitt that's right she's half
black and half fighters she black I
believe she was black
they make you decision especially in the
60s today go we want to do this for
social reasons and get a black Catwoman
or no I don't think so what we had was
every actor and actress in town we're
begging to be on the show well that's
why they created that walking up the
wall business big right there was so
much demand and pressure on the
producers and you had like Sammy Davis
jr. opening the window and you know Don
Ho and his that link and lurch and all
these people to chip person every
everybody was was on that that could get
on that show and there still was not
enough scenes for the is that was that
why they had that it's just so just
celebrities funny because the pressure
from all the agencies was like and their
kids of these celebrities were pound you
know let's get daddy why can't you get
on Batman mom why can't you get on that
show and every end is funny when there's
something successful everybody wants to
be a part of artists come on why didn't
why didn't the Joker shave his mustache
you know it's true he didn't want to
paint over the Mustang ridiculous I know
but but see that kind of bigger than
life you every one of these actors loved
playing these roles because they could
be more than just a human being
they could be villainous yeah like I
always my junker is a little different
than his you do a joker right yes I do
where you are
for the role of well I think one of the
animated Joker's as everyone's yeah what
was the audition like well the soubise I
had to do dialogue like wait do you
think we could do something fun maybe
maybe like that's what I'm saying like
hey stop right there Joker and then Jim
you can do your Joker would you want to
do that bird okay go okay you start on
our team want me to start yes yeah okay
Joker's stop where you are
Batman I know things up
Joker you sound like Riddler when you
snap into it it's it's a very crisp
yes great that was great well you know
you guys how you are you know there is a
scene in this new movie then this is
right up your alley
oh no okay okay and I don't want to
spoil the movie but what it's a scene
where Batman and Robin are tied down on
this gigantic pool table hmm right and
these huge pool balls are next to us
okay yeah and I had a line holy
humongous balls Batman I love it now
yesterday at our panel yeah they the
people that watched it cuz they had a
screening ball guy people they start
talking about this and I'm sitting next
to William Shatner and and and and he
says he starts in he is a real tease
this guy he is very oh let me tell you
he is sharper than a razor and he said
come on Bert say it for the audience you
know what I mean and then he had the
audience screaming and and did they say
well wait a minute we keep going back to
your book and then you're going back in
all of this stuff on would gone on
Batman and it was like my god his panel
became an inn not embarrassment but it
was a little more than I yes it was fine
but you stand into it that's a very
crisp
Robin delivery perfect and you know
speaking of what you were talking about
the panel I was just looking at the
Joker and I can guess what was what the
only thing that was more difficult to
hide than the Joker's mustache I bet it
was not Hubert
the thing is that like I got the nicest
compliment from the producers when I was
recording they interrupted my recording
and came out and said you know Burt you
sound exactly like you sounded 50 years
ago this is so much so that it's almost
scary that was the executive producer
say that to me
Jim Jim because I'm trying to be a
professional here yeah he passed gas and
it's really distracting cuz it stinks so
bad and I'm looking at our poor
cameraman over there is right next to
hit he's engulf I'm you're being a good
guy and not mentioning if I'm sure at
this point you can smell it well it's
embarrassing to me because I'm
associated with this nudnik and I don't
always want you guys make a great team
well I know you're kind of like the
dynamic duo of what of off-color
yes the dynamic duo just look at our
producer over there yeah he said all the
gossip oh yeah my Joker no he said it
sounded like the Riddler combination of
the combination Frank Gorshin was of
course the Riddler of course yes amazing
no I love the rubber face guy he was
he's a comedian impressionist oh the
best amazing
so whether different Riddler's or only
one with a different Joker's role he was
the second Riddler John Astin did one
segment one show is the Risen why only
one show what happened to frankly it no
but everybody liked Frank so much and he
was so great in and he was yeah first
one so they what they do is they would
try to give out a show here there just
to get more of these actors that were
begging to be on the show and and our
executive producer William Dozier had
been in the industry forever so he was
kind of beholden to some of these people
to try to I said sure get on now did you
stay friendly burgess Meredith of course
as the as the penguin did you you know a
let from Of Mice and Men he was just is
a legend by that point
oh yeah and
in other Rocky films of course many by
the time he did Batman which what years
they do back with you guys about 66 67
and 68 we did a hundred and twenty
episodes so the Rockies did not exist so
back then he was known for other other
work he Adagio he was very famous actor
he was well respected and he was he was
great as the penguin I mean he had a
real that character down he he had
stopped smoking years before and he was
forced to smoke because hey yeah yeah he
stopped years before it so it was a
quite a challenge for him to you know
they didn't have fake sick now I think
you could smoke it's different than an
action
you can't smoke cigarettes on set some
more but back then I guess they just
made him smoke all day well yeah that
and and you know our show was a very
dangerous show to make I don't know if
you know this why is that oh my gosh I
went into the emergency hospital for the
first six days of filming rather from
second-degree burns
two-by-fours breaking my nose I didn't
think I was gonna survive the first week
wait someone broke a board across your
face no no no here's what it was i if
you if you remember the first show I
don't know if you did I do I was tied to
a table and Batman was breaking through
the subway New York subway to rescue me
sure and they were supposed to build
what they call a breakaway set which is
balsa wood and with a small magnesium
charge and it sounds big you know and
all that and you know balsa wood just
falls apart
yeah well the set builders forgot to
build a breakaway set they built it like
a house with real two by fours there's
no time 80 guys on the crew 35,000 an
hour back in 66 to shoot this that's how
much across yeah
35,000 an hour and so there was no time
so what did they do these special
effects guys use two half sticks of
dynamite and nearly blew the entire
soundstage down when they did that you
know a 2x4 fell down and broke my nose
and I'm tied to a table I couldn't even
perfect protect my face oh wow
but you know I should have known
something was wrong because you know
it's a bad sign when it's 7:30 in the
morning you're tied to a table these
special effects guys walk past you can
you smell liquor on their breath oh my
god oh yeah
were they fired no I don't know I can
phezzan unions you know I guess
everybody else was
probably drinking on there to accept me